i quit
what
michael you have no idea how high i can
fly
oh no what
i'm going with him
what
pam
pam
you can't be serious
michael wait
i'm coming with you
you are
yeah
okay it's gonna be great
great uh except i don't wanna be a
receptionist anymore
right
executive assistant salesman
all right
okay
deal deal
okay well jim still know okay yeah i
think you should get dressed i'm not
getting dressed i'm not getting dressed
i have too many things to do before i
get dressed
i need to find 100 clients michael that
seems impossible it's totally impossible
we need to come up with
one realistic thing that we could do
today assemble a sales team a dream team
great
we got vikram you got me
look i'm sorry to do this but can you
drop me back at the telemarketing
building well it's always been a
lifelong michael
what's going on i am poor hey ryan
excuse me yes this wasn't on the list
yes it is no yes it's not it is
when did you add this to the list pam
everyone deserves a second second chance
ryan just out of curiosity how much do
you get paid here 60 000 a year
you get paid by the year at the bowling
alley what do you make secretary back to
work shoe [ __ ]
i told you guys i'm really busy here
would you like to come to work for the
michael scott paper company
what size shoes you guys i'll have nine
what are those men's ten no okay what
he's doing what is he doing he's
stealing him okay okay oh my god he's
already paying for himself sorry
where is it right here
hey come on guys these are prime selling
hours you know
michael i don't know about this nana
i really think that papa would want you
to do this
i'm not so sure well what is it exactly
i mean what what specifically we don't
it doesn't have to be paper we could
sell
medicine and other see this is what
concerns me we could just give him a
chance it's not much money well
this might not be the right time but i
need more than i originally asked this
isn't a handout club it's an investment
club okay
i love you michael i do okay but no
i mean it no
okay
i could work here
i could see this
it's right in the middle of the paper
belt
are you good
yeah i'm good
you good
i'm good
you know what they say
keep your friends close
michael scott paper company this is pam
hi russell from the pancake luncheon how
are you
well we'd like to do business with you
too
how can i make that happen
we
they don't know that
um i can offer you free delivery on any
order that you placed today
okay
20 boxes uh i can do just a second right
here i can do 20 boxes at 43 dollars a
box
great
write it down
give me okay i guarantee you what i'm
saying
and i guarantee
that
you will be satisfied
because your satisfaction is our
guarantee we guarantee it
we look forward to doing business with
you too
thank you russell
yes i made a sale
yeah
yeah yeah and say hello to uh sherry
who is your black wife
[Applause]
so you're begging for mercy huh well you
will find none here do i do mine if we
talk sure
that'd be fine if you keep coming after
us the michael scott paper company
cannot succeed
this is war and that is what happens oh
one more thing i'm going to have you
listen while i steal your biggest client
oh no no no no no oh wow michael michael
you down right now mike you can hear me
but i can't hear you scofield's ready to
see you now mr scott great mr
schofield's ready to see me thank you so
much don't let him in he's a trainer
michael good to see you mr schofield
good to see you
and
i'm closing the door
okay who covers band's pet grooming oh
they're in my clan no
they were your clan they just called
said they're switching over to michael
scott paper company ah
shame jim i expected more in the last
month we have lost 10 major clients to
michael scott what are we supposed to do
they keep undercutting us on price i
don't want to hear excuses i want to see
improvements this is unacceptable how
much can we afford to pay a delivery guy
well if these numbers you gave me are
correct they are correct sir then you
can't afford to pay him anything okay
a lame attempt at humor swinging a miss
your prices are too low lowest in town
why do you think staples in dunder
mifflin can't match your prices
corporate greed look our pricing model
is fine i review the numbers myself over
time with enough volume we become
profitable yeah with the fixed cost
pricing model that's correct yeah but
you need to use a variable cost pricing
model okay sure
right so
why don't you explain what that is to
this so they can under yeah just explain
what that is explain what you think that
is okay just explain it as you sell more
paper and your company grows so will
your costs for example delivery man
health care
business expansion whatever yeah so at
these prices the more paper you sell the
less money you'll make our prices are
the only thing keeping us in business
they're actually putting you out of
business okay okay hold on hold on
ty
i would like you to crunch those numbers
again
it's programmed there's no such thing
just crunch them just crunch them please
crunch
did it help
hey
can i talk to you guys for a second
we're not hiring jim i'm actually here
for something else listen i can't make
you laugh right now you know i love a
good guessing game but why don't i just
tell you what i'm here for turns out you
guys have made a pretty big dent in the
dunder mifflin sales well that's nice so
david wallace has asked me to come down
here and see if you would be interested
in dunder mifflin buying you out
seriously are you being serious are you
bluffing pam jim what you don't
understand is that this company's worse
oh
no
we don't have oh
see i'm here to learn as little
information as possible all i really
need to hear is if you're incredibly
successful company would be receptive to
a buyout
yes yes maybe three yeses i will see
titans of industry upstairs your company
is four weeks old i know this business i
know what suppliers are charging i know
you can't be making very much money i
don't know how your prices are so low
but i know it can't keep up that way
i'm sure you're scared
probably in debt that's the best offer
you're gonna get
i'll see your situation and i'll raise
you a situation
your company is losing clients left and
right you have a stockholder meeting
coming up and you're going to have to
explain to them why your most profitable
branch
is bleeding
so they may be looking for a little
change in the cfo so i don't think i
need to wait out dunder mifflin i think
i just have to wait out you
there are certain defining moments in a
person's life
the day he's born the day he grows hair
the day he starts a business and the day
he sells that business back to dunder
mifflin
what have i learned from all of this
it is far too early to tell i just know
that i am flying high and i don't even
want to think about it i just want to
enjoy it
hey guys oh no you're done
things are a little slow here and
there's only so much cold calling you
can do in a day
turns out there's no limit to the number
of cheese puffs you can throw at
someone's face
we're getting pretty good at it
yes
[Music]
you